[Music]
one thing that can ruin your movie-going
experience is if the actor doesn't quite
look the part
gary oldman won the 2018 Best Actor
Oscar Award for playing Winston
Churchill a political leader he looks
nothing like take full responsibility
really yes his success was in large part
thanks to the makeup and prosthetics
team who also won Oscars for their work
on darkest hour we've all seen bad
prosthetics and movies that just makes
the work makeup designers do so much
more important but how exactly does it
work
makeup designers will often use a
process called life casting essentially
they cover an actor in goop to create an
exact replica then they use that replica
to build prosthetics for the actor to
wear gary oldman went through extensive
life casting and even Heidi Klum did it
for the costume she wore to her annual
Halloween bash to figure out exactly how
the process works we talked to makeup
designer Arion Teigen he was just
nominated for an Oscar for his work in
the movie wonder in the movie Jacob
Tremblay plays Oggy
a boy with Treacher Collins syndrome
which had to be approached sensitively
Jacob is wearing to give the illusion
that he has Treacher Collins syndrome
he's wearing silicone prosthetics all
the way from the neck up to the chin to
the cheeks it took the wonder team 20
minutes to create an exact life cast of
Jacob Tremblay the GUP mentioned earlier
is actually alginate a molding material
made from seaweed extract commonly used
in life casting while the team work
their magic
Tremblay could only breathe through his
nose the crew had to be very careful and
make sure they didn't spread any
alginate honest nostrils
life passes on forth to get the
impression of the face get an exact
duplicate is as accurate as possible
this is his original life cast it's a
copy of his head and shoulders once we
have this we start sculpting certain
shapes we need to create a makeup a
prosthetic makeup is typically made of
fleshy silicone when making prosthetics
you need to be extra mindful of every
little detail for Oggy the makeup team
had to punch in his eyebrows
individually they even made a wired
under skull for him to wear that could
be used to pull his eyes down to be as
realistic as possible
I spoke with children who had this
condition Trembley also wore fake teeth
and awake usually it can take hours to
fully apply prosthetics to an actor
because Tremblay is so young they are
able to get it done in just 90 minutes
nowadays a lot of movies rely on CGI to
bring characters to life but when it can
be done there is nothing like the craft
that goes into a movies prosthetic
makeup
you
[Music]